Hey guys, and welcome to a brand new
video. Today, we're going to be going
over a money-making method that made me
about 2.2 mil in an hour. And uh it's
going to be with your farming skill.
Now, there isn't a set farming level
you're going to need for this. You will
need the farming level corresponding to
the seed you want to use cuz what we'll
be doing is creating saplings out of
seeds, and you will need the farming
level to do that. Uh so, for the willow
seed, you'll need uh 30 farming. For the
maple seed, you'll need 45 farming. Uh
for the yew seed, you'll need 60
farming, etc., etc. Uh have a look
through your fruit tree section of your
farming guide as well as your regular
tree section cuz those are the uh seeds
we'll be using. All right, hope you guys
enjoy, and let's get started. Okay, so
you can see in my Grand Exchange, I have
uh a few different seeds coming through.
Now, ideally, you're going to want to
diversify the seeds you're buying. And
the main reason that is is because uh
the buy limit on each of the seeds is
just 200. Uh so, the more uh seeds you
have, like the different types, the
quicker overall it'll take for your
offers to come through. I don't have
this set up perfectly. Uh honestly, you
should be buying either 200, 400, or 600
of each seed. Buying 500 is kind of just
a waste of time. Uh but it just kind of
worked out that's how much money I had
left over. Um ideally, you'd probably
buy 400 of four different seeds, and
that would take uh well, about 5 hours
maybe for the full offers to come
through. Uh so, there is definitely a
little bit of pre-planning necessary,
but it's really not too bad. So, we'll
take out 600 curry seeds,
500 willow seeds, and 400 yew seeds
being by far the most expensive.
So, one thing that I forgot to mention a
lot in my money-making videos is
absolutely before you actually do this
method, check the margin of the item
you're going to be doing. There are a
bunch of different seeds to do.
Uh so let's just go ahead and pick one
and I'll show you. So let's say you go
to your farming guide and let's go fruit
trees. How about this time? And let's
look at um
papaya tree seeds. How about? So let's
go ahead and all you're going to do is
buy a papaya tree seed. And you're going
to buy and sell it.
And just do it instantly. So you're
going to crank up the price and sell it.
Uh so we're going to be attempting to
buy these seeds for
uh 9851.
And now you're going to buy the papaya
uh sapling.
And insta buy that as well.
And uh sell that off. So we're going to
be selling them for about 11927.
And I will be buying them for 9 851,
hopefully.
Uh which is actually a really good
margin for I'm going to put an offer in
for these right now. Uh
2K on item this cheap is extremely good.
So yeah, make sure you absolutely check
the margin cuz
uh this doesn't always work. The prices
don't always line up. So it's better to
just know in advance so you don't waste
uh your time or money. So as you can see
here, there are many different seeds
that have varying different levels of
cost. Now the curry seed, only 316K for
all. Well, I guess more closer to 400K
for 600 of them. Very cheap. And when I
checked it, it had about a 600 GP margin
on each one. Uh which is still pretty
good. Willow seeds, more of a medium
price item. About 4 mil for all the
seeds, about 500 of them. And then
there's stuff like U seeds which cost 34
mil for 400 of them, but they do tend to
have a larger margin. Uh so now we're
going to deposit the seeds in the bank.
Okay, so we have our three different
seeds that we're going to be combining.
Now you can do between 1500 and 1700
seeds per hour. Now this is based on the
assumption that you have completed um
the Dream Mentor quest and have access
to the Lunar spellbook. Uh and the spell
in particular is Humidify. You do not
require this. It's just going to speed
this up by quite a bit uh, because
otherwise you have to manually water
each of your uh, seeds, which is a
little more time consuming, but it'll
probably cut your time down in about by
30% or something by having the spell,
maybe half. Uh, and uh, which is pretty
substantial.
But I a lot of the time is spent waiting
for the seeds to buy, so it's not really
the end of the world if you don't have
it, but I would recommend it. So, what
we're going to do initially is just
withdraw all your seeds cuz they are
stackable. So, we're going to go ahead
and withdraw, let's do the cheapest ones
first. Let's do the curry tree seeds.
And what you need to withdraw is
a bunch of filled plant pots, and you're
also going to need a gardening trowel.
So, once you have all that in your
inventory, all you have to do is bring
uh, the seed down to the bottom corner
is what I recommend doing, and uh, you
honestly can just spam click these
together. Uh, you can do it pretty
quick. Now, there is a way to kind of
double click here,
which does actually speed things up a
bit cuz as you can see,
I am clicking
clicking to use it on that item and then
instantly re-clicking on item, clicking
on this one to use it, instantly
re-clicking on the item, and then you
just kind of do a double click, uh,
which I find to be the easiest motion
and also much less click intensive. Once
you've finished up an inventory, all you
do is deposit the curry tree saplings or
whatever sapling you have, and go ahead
and withdraw more planted uh, filled
plant pots. So, I'm going to go ahead
and fill all these curry tree saplings,
and then I will show you how to water
them. Okay, so I ended up all of the
planter pots, all 1,500 of them. It took
about 25 minutes to do it. Uh, so let's
just say half an hour for the ease of
uh, my brain, I guess. Uh, so now comes
the easy part. So, I'm going to show you
the easy way first, and then I'll show
you how you do it without the humidify
spell. So, what you're going to want is
a steam battle staff, as well as some
astral runes. You'll need about uh, 100
to 200 for this many um, plants. Uh, so
all you're going to have to do is
withdraw all of whatever sapling you
want and then just cast your Humidify
spell. Boom, done, banked, and that's
all 27 done. Uh, so it's going to be so
quick. It's really not going to be that
time-consuming to do this. Just boom,
done,
bank them, and it'll probably only take
I don't know, 5 to 10 minutes to do all
these. So really not that long at all.
As you can see how quickly that could be
done. Otherwise, the only other way to
do this is using watering cans, uh,
which is a pain. Um, I don't even have
any filled ones here. I'll just show you
the the basics. You're just going to
withdraw the curry saplings and then
you're going to do something similar.
Just drop it down here and, uh, spam
click them together. It's kind of
time-consuming. Plus, you need to go
fill these up since you cannot buy them
filled, uh, which is a really annoying
as well. And they will run out. You can
see I'm on to watering can three.
Uh, but you need about three per
inventory.
And yeah, so that's that. I wouldn't
recommend doing that so much, but
honestly, it's not It's just more
clicking. I would definitely say it's
worth getting the Humidify spell, but
not required. So we'll go ahead and, uh,
finish humidifying all of these plants
and I'll be back in a few minutes. Okay,
guys. So we finished up all of the
seeds, watering them with the Humidify
spell. Took about 8 minutes to do all of
them. So really not that long at all.
Uh, as you, uh, if you are following
along with this, you might notice that
some of your plants have fully turned
into saplings. It takes about 5 minutes
or so. And all Honestly, just need to
leave them. There's nothing you can
really do. Uh, really annoying thing
I've noticed is you can actually
withdraw these noted, which is kind of
weird. So anyway, um, in total, I've
spent 40 minutes doing this so far. You
could count an extra 5 minutes waiting
for these to turn, uh, into, uh, the
saplings, but I mean, if you were doing
this for a long time, it wouldn't be 5
minutes every hour. It'd just be 5
minutes at the end. So whatever. Let's
just say 45 minutes to do this all in
total. Plus, we have to, uh, wait for
these guys. So I'll we for those guys,
let's go ahead and just uh, well, we'll
dump in the rest of the items we have.
So, we want to definitely price check
this cuz I bought these yesterday. So,
the prices could have changed pretty
drastically. So, let's go with the curry
sapling to begin with. So, let's see
what we got the curry sapling for. And
1103. So, that's still pretty good. We
bought them yesterday for 632
each for each seed. So, 1103 minus 632,
which is 471 per sapling. And we did 600
saplings, giving us about 282k,
which isn't bad for how cheap this item
was.
We're hoping to get better margins for
the other items, but this is pretty
good. 1102.
So, we'll sell it for 662k.
And then moving on to the willow
sapling, kind of a mid-range item. And
that we bought the sapling for 8900.
Now, what did we buy the yew seeds for?
Or sorry, the willow seeds for. It looks
like 7800. So, we're going to be getting
a little bit over 1k on each one. So,
we'll pop those in for 8899. Okay, and
it looks like in our bank, the rest of
the yew saplings have been converted.
So, now we have 400 yew seeds. Like I
said, I had a couple in my bank already.
So, now let's go ahead and check yew
sapling price.
So, it looks like yew saplings are going
for 89988.
And we bought the yew seeds for 87k.
So, that is a 2k margin on the yew
seeds, which is really nice. Can I pop
them in for 89987.
These won't take long to sell.
So, I'll pop back in once they have sold
and we'll see how much we made in total.
All right, guys. Everything has sold off
and we made quite a bit of profit on all
of the items.
Let's start off with the curry sapling.
Now, we sold them all for 662k
each. We ended up getting a 470 GP
margin on this item.
While we didn't get as much money as the
other seeds.
This actually ended up giving us almost
double our initial
cash amount, which would be really
useful if you don't actually have a lot
of money to work with. I mean, we only
paid like 350k for it and we sold it for
660,
netting us 282k
off of a very cheap seed, which is nice.
Next up is the willow seed we ended up
selling for 8899, kind of a mid-range
seed. We ended up getting a 1038
key merged on this seed,
giving us about 520k in profit. Very
cost effective cuz while the U seed did
give us a better profit,
vastly more expensive. So, the willow
seed was only like 5 mil and the U seed
was 35 mil.
Anyway, moving on to the U seed,
which we sold for 89987.
We ended up getting a item
and 400 seeds gives us 880k
in total
from the U seeds, which is awesome.
Again, really expensive but if you have
the money, definitely go for it. So,
let's just add up 282 plus 520 plus 8
80, giving us 1.6 mil in about 45
minutes.
In about 2.2 mil an hour. I
underestimated how quickly I would be
able to actually
process the seeds. It really doesn't
take that long. Just keep in mind that
you have to put some offers in in
advance and the more you can diversify
your items, the quicker they'll come
through.
So, hope you guys enjoyed the video.
Definitely give it a try and I will see
you guys in the next one.
Woo!